[Music]
this is a this is a dumb boring question
but anybody got uh least favorite
airlines
spirit spirit used to be spirit now jet
blue [ __ ] jet blue oh why
i took them here one time they delayed
my flight twice and then when i was on
the flight it was it was actually really
shitty they used to have the number one
i thought they were the best i thought i
thought they were [ __ ] too yeah and then
i dealt with them recently i was like oh
yo y'all trash wait they don't they
don't compensate you like because every
time jetblue uh this is pre-pandemic
every time i had a late flight i didn't
even have to request like or complain
they would just say we're giving you a
discount and we're charging we're giving
you back some money for our for your
inconvenience no how about the the the
the dope snack tray when they walked
around with the blue chips all right all
right i [ __ ] with that snack
all right you know what you know what
you know the sanctuary yeah it's true
yeah fine fine i don't want you over
there
i had a pop edge fine listen and you can
go over and get the snacks yourself
because they have more right well yeah
if you want more sleep can you still
yeah
i just took it like like last week
flown around in europe have you guys
heard of ryanair yeah oh yeah isn't that
the jet blue of europe or the spirit
yeah it's it's also really really shitty
it's like super i'm
it's one of those cost-efficient
airlines yeah yeah yeah but they had
those costs in other areas yeah so like
so like you don't like your knees are
always touching the front chair like you
have to pay for like [ __ ] napkins
like no yeah no person no no you gotta
pay for that you gotta paint it because
like a legion you can't even
that's the same with spirit yeah i did
first class for spirit and the seats
don't recline
that's just first class for spirit is it
really first time i know it's [ __ ]
yeah
so there were some uh some people on
holiday all right that were in disbelief
with ryanair after the plane took off
without them
[Laughter]
that's really funny how did that happen
it's an empty plane that just flew off
everyone's in the terminal still yeah
that's so [ __ ] good i need to look
that up
like that just shows where they're
thinking about their customers yeah like
all the way they just think about
they're just thinking about time bro
they just said [ __ ] it who are they
talking to when they demonstrate this
oh yeah so a reported group of 14 were
stranded at palma airport in mallorca on
saturday as a pilot flew off without
them and the holiday goers were already
checked in and had arrived at the gate
on time to discover they were unable to
board the plane
yeah
just [ __ ] was like hey man we gotta
close the door
i know we can come through hey
apparently the mistake was on an airport
handler who operates the airport shuttle
bus at palmer de mallorca so you know
sometimes like especially on these more
economy flights you're not going
straight onto the plane you gotta go
that's like from like built in like the
70s or some [ __ ] you got to take this
like jenkins bus and it takes you like
14 miles to some random place and then
you get on a really really small planet
yeah and that guy's name was all of our
dad if you're late we're going without
you
we're going without you
that's the reason yeah
so there was said to be no room on the
final bus as you'd expect uh passengers
started waiting for the next shuttle to
arrive and it never came never camp what
a weird thing man
yeah is that ryanair it's the shuttle
yeah shuttle's wall it's that airport
but at the same time it's like it's
ryanair you know what i mean it's it's
not but also some of these flights that
they'll hold for people yeah they didn't
just wait yeah because i remember one
time i was flying uh
i was flying somewhere
i think it was to canada or something
and uh
they were like uh i had a layover in
seattle
and
the takeoff was like a later time like
it got delayed and i was like oh what's
the problem did i go weather i'm like
[ __ ]
i was like it's sunny as [ __ ] out there
you're talking about weather it's
tuesday and i looked at the weather in
canada i was like brother
no [ __ ] way there's no [ __ ] way
they were waiting for another plane to
land so those people can make it
to and it's like just say that i'm okay
with that it's too sunny
better yeah
i thought the
the flight attendant's supposed to
communicate with the front desk and like
is everyone checked in that's what i'm
saying like even even the person when
you when you have a flight right when
you go to the check-in that person is
checking you in is oftentimes still
checking you into the actual final plane
too like it's the same team that goes
with you all the way and sometimes
they're even the stewardess on the
flight yeah you know what i'm saying so
it's kind of like if if they walk you in
at the beginning they need to walk you
all the way into the flight and off
their fault my little my little brother
is an air traffic controller or used to
be and dude he's told me some [ __ ] up
story like give us the [ __ ] though yeah
that's cool it's like you know he's like
yeah so i guess a lot of us should have
been out on the floor but we were
playing mario kart in the back
like [ __ ] like that right
this kid drives everywhere now he
doesn't [ __ ] fly anymore i thought
air traffic controllers was like one of
the most stressful jobs in the world
it's got to be stressful so i got decoy
i think that was them decompressing
playing [ __ ] car real quick on the
job though decompress after work
everyone everyone's a human being it's
like those surgeons doing tick tocks and
stuff and the guy's guts are all out
i don't know
i think there's tears to that human
being
no i like that you're right
you went to the [ __ ]
humanize them bro
yeah do you remember when this [ __ ]
happened to us in detroit
[ __ ] detroit out of all places right
like we were on a delta flight and then
it was like a transfer or something like
that we'd get there and then so we had a
couple hours before flight we're like
all right cool we checked in let's go
grab some burger king yeah whatever we
went to the front desk and stuff and
then they're like oh no your flight's
not ready yet so i'm like alright cool
we're gonna go eat this burger king so
we go eat burger king we come back and
then always eat that so the door is
closed and then we're early like it says
on the ticket you know be there before
this time whatever whatever and then
we're like we're early and we're like we
see the plane right there can we get on
and they're like uh
the doors closed once it's closed you
can't get on i'm like you guys closed it
before the it says
boarding on the ticket i first just said
they didn't let you on no no no she said
they left already i'm like no it's right
there yeah
there's a window
like once they close the door they can't
open it again yes they can the gaslight
airlines i know right yeah
right here there's no plane bro that's
an
they shut that door and then they oh my
god there's a fire in there and then
they look at the pilot they're just like
open it
no we can't open it you know that
already
i know
i just holding the glass i'm like the
plane's right there let us go on and
then they literally wouldn't let y'all
know we were within the boarding time
and i think it was a small flight
because it was one of those transfer
ones okay and so like they thought that
everyone was there so they just shut the
gates and then because of protocol
they're like we can't open it back up
and i'm like but you guys shut the gate
early so technically you can open it
back up because it's still within the
boarding time window true and then they
started interpreting the ticket to me to
me and they're like no it says on or
before this time and i'm like
yeah
that's on or before and they were
looking at me like i didn't know you
know they tried to hit you with it i
thought you were stupid
i'm like brother try to install your
intelligence
on or before and i'm like before
it's 45 minutes before the flight like
you know what you're like my [ __ ] ex
wow
you're not listening to me yeah they're
like
they're like saying it's slow like you
know when you talk to someone dumb
they're like on or before they were
looking at me and part like like do you
know english and i was like what the
[ __ ] it is i'm eating airport burger
king i'm an american
clearly overpriced 90 dollars of [ __ ]
bags
and then we're just like so what are we
going to do now and then they're like
uh we'll just get you on the next flight
and we're like cool tomorrow morning at
6 00 a.m and i'm like what are we gonna
do and then they just basically got us
like vouchers to stay across the street
at a hotel
and then we just knocked out for like
four hours and then we just got up early
and left and i was like that was the
weirdest experience i've ever had yeah
yeah that
though i recently found out i think all
the uh airline rules are actually
optional so i was flying wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait where are you
yeah so i'll so you know usually you go
through tsa you gotta take off your
shoes you got this whole ordeal right
not if you've got pre-check yeah and
i signed up for pre-check and doesn't
show up on my [ __ ] boarding pass but
anyways like the uh the escalator and
the elevator was shut down so there's
this huge pile up
right and then out of nowhere the tsa
guy gets up on like the uh the
loudspeaker thing and he was just like
all right everyone keep your laptops in
your backpack don't take off your shoes
only walk through the metal detectors
and all of a sudden that big ass pileup
it just cleared up in a second and i'm
like so you're telling me anytime we
want we don't have to do it oh yeah this
is true that that is true that's
happened to me before where they're like
no no no don't take your shoes off okay
what what i'm like then if that's okay
why don't we do this all the time
because you gotta pay for it you know
the answer they it's a money thing they
they built out their little corporate
ecosystem now where it's like hey you
want the nice thing where it's easy like
it used to be go pay you gotta go yeah
because uh it's like pre-checks global
entry it's clear they have like 18
different versions yeah yeah yeah dude
it's just because you think started
happening at what night after 9 11 yeah
shoe bomber guy yeah tsa in general
really happened after 9 11. yeah that's
true yeah oh really he always had metal
detector because i never traveled before
911 i'm a post 911 traveler
pre-911 traveler and
i remember he saw 911 was like there was
a metal detector
i want to go on a plane
but my mom said before
before there wasn't any metal detectors
you just go get your ticket and then
anyone can go up to the to to the free
they used to be able to smoke on planes
yeah yeah before you could before even
if you weren't flying you could go to
the gate with your friend and you can
hug them out you know what i mean oh
yeah
yeah anymore dude like in dumb and
dumber when he chases after that yeah
i'm just gonna stay
he got all the way through that little
tube thing
yeah but then like terrorism and drug
trafficking changed it all yeah changed
it all man
[Music]
you